schönen guten tag nach lemberg
moskalenko
wir sprechen die aktuell die flüchtlinge
die wir natürlich aufnehmen wollen dazu
verpflichtet sind und das auch wirklich
tun wollen und wir sprechen darüber was
alles noch auf uns zukommen wird in
diesem schrecklichen krieg vielleicht
können sie uns da schon ein gradmesser
geben denn sie haben ja ebenfalls
flüchtlingskrise sozusagen bei sich
neben dem natürlich alles
überstrahlenden krieg wie viele menschen
müssen sie aktuell in lemberg
unterbringen
es ist schon eine sehr wichtige frage
wenn wir davon ausgehen dass nicht viele
menschen in der welt licht diese
schrecklichen sachen vorstellen können
die in meinem heimatland
unglaubliche situation eine völkern
apathischen in maribor wo viele gebäude
zerstört hatten sie nur leute war es
genau heute morgen so dass wir wieder
traurige geschichten gehört haben dass
eine kunst schule bombardiert wurde von
rosen in der vergangenheit war es auch
in dein bindungs klinik er ein theater
was bombardiert wurden ist oft leiden
kinder und frauen darunter gerade in
solch einer situation
frauen immer wieder auf der suche
gewesen nach sichere zuflucht sie wollen
ihre leben das leben ihrer kinder
sichern
großen ist es egal das militär ist oder
kinder sie bombardieren alle
110 kinder sind ja schon von den dosen
umgebracht worden in diesem krieg in
diesem fall jetzt hier in lemberg haben
wir über 200.000 menschen
aus anderen ukrainischen städten zu uns
gekommen sind
ukrainerinnen und ukrainer
binnenvertriebene sind bleiben auch
jetzt erstmal hier einige tage sie
müssen entscheiden wie es weiter gehen
zu wollen sie bei uns bleiben wollen sie
ins ausland weiter zu ihm möglicherweise
eine andere ukrainische stadt umziehen
insofern ist das für uns sehr wichtig im
moment ihr diese entscheidung zu treffen
im moment muss ich sagen wir sind noch
in einer verhältnismäßig ruhigen lage
auf der luftraum ist sicher insofern ist
es für uns wichtig dass wir alle
berlinerinnen ukraine schutz geben
werden die russen
der landesmitte und dem osten die städte
zerstören wir haben nur eine lösung wir
müssen bis zum ende durchhalten und
kämpfen es ist unser land sind unsere
steht wir haben kein anderes land
kann ich nur sagen wir sind geeint wir
sind ein land und noch eine sache die
ich keinen unterstreichen möchte die
gesamte welt musste wissen dass
es kein krieg zwischen russland und der
ukraine ist es ist ein krieg zwischen
russland und der gesamten welt
was heute geschieht mit dem ukrainischen
kindern
betrifft auch alle demokratien in dieser
wertung dass seine frage die sich die
gesamte welt stellen muss wie können sie
die ukraine um die reale demokratie
unterstützen sie haben hat all die
menschen angesprochen die innerhalb der
ukraine geflüchtet sind und sich zu
ihnen erstmal geflüchtet haben und sie
haben dann gesagt die werden sich in den
nächsten tagen entscheiden ob sie weiter
ziehen oder in lemberg bleiben was
glauben sie wie deren entscheidungen
ausfallen wird nachdem wir ja zunehmend
auch erschreckende meldungen aus der
nähe von lemberg oder auch direkt aus
lemberg hören und sehen
in den letzten wochen etwa
hatten wir leider traurige nachrichten
bekommen dass ungefähr 40 kilometer vor
der stadt von
ein großes für friedenseinsätze von
russischen raketen getroffen worden ist
insgesamt acht flugkörper sind dort
eingeschlagen und das sind wirklich
schlechte das sind traurige nachrichten
35 unsere ukrainischen helden sind
gestorben über 100 menschen wurden mit
diesem angriff verletzt und auch vor
zwei tagen am morgen wurde wieder
eine fabriken in der nähe des flughafens
angegriffen und ja wenn man so will ist
das auch ein signal das signal geht
nicht nur an lemberg oder an der ukraine
sondern auch ein klares signal an europa
niemand ist mehr sicher
nur 20 kilometer sind wir entfernt von
der grenze eines eu-staates eines nato
statt also eine ganz klare botschaft
dass für uns im moment hier keine
sicherheit mehr gegen kommen
ich hatte bereits gesagt das ist
verhältnismäßig nicht im moment noch
aber es ist absolut notwendig dass die
gesamte welt die eu nato druck ausüben
muss auf muss man ansonsten kommt dieser
konflikt immer näher an die eu was
würden sie all den menschen die zu ihm
nach lemberg gekommen sind raten würden
sie den acta erwarten ganz menschlich
ihr könnt guten gewissens hier bleiben
oder würden sie ehrlicherweise sagen am
besten wenn ihr die chance habt geht
richtung westen
viele leute die zu uns gekommen sind
sind natürlich unter stress
insofern
standorte in der stadt wo sie
unterkommen wo sie schlafen können wo
sie lebensmittel bekommen wir kümmern
uns um sie und bereiten sie vor
sozusagen auf ihrem nächsten
entscheidung dabei kann ich sagen dass
viele leute bleiben wollen oft sie
wollen in ihrem land bleiben andere die
natürlich unter belastung stehen und
stresst die
wollen natürlich die stadt verlassen und
das machen sie auch und dank der
unterstützung von nachbarstaaten der
europäischen union
also was ist es wichtig dass die
unterstützung in
schwierigen zeiten
russland unser land man greift ich sagte
dass wir kämpfen wir stellen uns dagegen
insofern können wir eines mit sicherheit
sagen
das was jetzt passiert ist unsicher wir
wissen nicht was heute abend passieren
kann noch vor vier wochen hätte niemand
sagen können dass die hauptstadt eines
der größten länder in europa angegriffen
wird noch vor vier wochen hätte niemand
gedacht dass die russen angreifen und
zwar vollkommen wahllos kinder hätten
schulen sie wollen unser land dominiert
also wie gesagt unsere reaktion kann nur
einer sein wir kämpften bis zum schluss
es ist unser land wir haben kein anderes
überall gibt es auch leute die
zurückkommen
zurückkommen wollen die ukraine
im ausland gearbeitet haben sie sind
bereit
um ihr land zu verteidigen um die
binnenflüchtlinge kümmern wir uns
was wir tun können wesen und weitergehen
sollen
bereits viele sind geflüchtet
die eu staaten und das ist eine
persönliche entscheidung einige von
denen sind zum teil wieder einmal im
blick zurück gekommen danke dass wir sie
in unserer sendung heute haben durften
an den vize bürgermeister von lemberg
andrej moskalenko danke